tout en étant compatible avec la fabrication à grande échelle.
C'est aussi une très jeune technologie. Nous débutons juste.
On a beaucoup d'idées sur comment améliorer nettement les performances,
avec de nouveaux matériaux et designs pour atteindre un niveau de performance
au-delà des muscles biologiques et des traditionnels moteurs électriques rigides.
En allant vers des designs plus complexes pour la bio-robotique -
voici notre scorpion artificiel
qui peut utiliser sa queue pour chasser des proies,
dans ce cas, un ballon.
(Rires)
Revenons à notre inspiration initiale,
la flexibilité des tentacules de pieuvre et de trompe d'éléphant,
nous pouvons maintenant construire des actionneurs continus mous
qui se rapprochent de plus en plus de la capacité du réel.
Je suis très excité sur les applications pratiques
des muscles artificiels HASEL.
Ils vont permettre des robots mous
qui peuvent améliorer la qualité de vie.
Ils vont favoriser une nouvelle génération de prothèse plus réaliste
pour les personnes qui ont perdu une partie de leur corps.
Vous pouvez voir ici des HASEL de mon laboratoire,
les premiers tests, pour une prothèse de doigt.
Un jour, on pourra peut-être fusionner nos corps avec des pièces de robotique.
Je sais qu'à première vue, cela semble effrayant.
Mais quand je pense à mes grands-parents
et à la façon dont ils deviennent plus dépendants des autres
pour réaliser les tâches quotidiennes comme seulement utiliser les toilettes,
ils se sentent souvent comme s'ils étaient un fardeau.
Avec la robotique souple, on sera capable d'améliorer et de restaurer
l'agilité et la dextérité,
et ainsi aider les personnes âgées à maintenir leur autonomie
plus longtemps dans leur vie.
Nous pouvons peut-être appeler cela « la robotique anti-vieillissement »
ou même la prochaine étape de l'évolution humaine.
Contrairement à leurs homologues rigides,
les robots souples réalistes agiront sans danger et nous aideront à la maison.
La robotique souple est un nouveau domaine qui commence juste.
J'espère que beaucoup de jeunes personnes de milieux différents
nous rejoindront dans cette aventure passionnante
et développeront le futur de la robotique
en introduisant de nouveaux concepts inspirés par la nature.
Si on le fait bien,
on peut améliorer la qualité de vie
pour nous tous.
Merci.
(Applaudissements)